it's ironic that Disney decided not to
do any more of the Fantasia series
because for the next couple of films
they be trying endlessly to try and
recreate it make my music was probably
the first attempt to try and do that you
follow sort of a similar formula to what
Three Caballeros was doing just tying
together a series of shorts with a
certain kind of music
although Three Caballeros where they had
a character at least tying the stories
together though loosely this one they
just show the shorts again much like
Fantasia except the music is in
classical music it's more music that was
popular at the time in fact some of it
if I understand correctly was left over
from Fantasia the animation for blue Bay
you actually makes it into this one
which was originally supposed to be
featured in a sequel to Fantasia except
instead of using the classical music
they use a song instead later the
original would be released on DVD and
it's a lot better make my music it's
probably closer to what Three Caballeros
was trying to be sort of a fun series of
short stories they were very loosely
tied together with one theme this one
you guessed it it music well some
classical does make it in for example we
do a Peter in the wolf though it does
have a narrator as well but it works
okay we also have a short that really
seems to have nothing to do with music
remember the cartoon mighty Casey up
Tibet
yeah it's from this it's a great story
and it's hilarious but what's it have to
do with music is talking and rhyming
really the same well however you want to
take it it's still great to watch here
the short stories work a lot better
some just create atmosphere others tell
a full narrative and they're all pretty
solid I can't think of any part I
particularly didn't like favorite
moments include Casey again Peter and
the wolf but by far my favorite is the
singing whale with all the singing
voices done by one person throughout the
entire thing that is awesome phonetic
way
I doubted David I know a lot of people
probably haven't seen this cartoon so
without giving anything away let's just
say that sad face yeah big clue it's
another one of those bittersweet moments
that probably leaves a few kids confused
but I like that it wasn't totally sad
but it's definitely not happy either and
on top of that you're getting some great
music and one hell of a great singer
modern to classic to jazz they cover a
pretty impressive gamut and while
nothing hits quite as potent as Fantasia
does it is still pretty enjoyable this
is another example of a bunch of
cartoons that were taken from this movie
and then chopped up into shorts and
there's a reason they work really well
so if you ever want to see them all
together
check this movie out it's a good one